you probably had boyfriends in your life
or somebody you was getting to know
right now not now not before um yes okay
your dad will be worried calling are you
okay yeah yeah yes okay good he will
check up on you yes why woman a woman
needs trust yes security love yeah thank
you imagine you come and break it break
it break it how are you going to trust
the next man that comes the way this is
how Islam protects woman number one
speak to the father why now the man is
thinking speak to the
father I don't want marriage I just want
to around I'm speaking to your father oh
now you know what he's about do you see
now now now do you agree yeah okay
good dear brothers and sisters as we
watch what is unfolding today in Gaza we
have to understand that opposition is
counting on us to lose attention to
become fatigued and to move on with the
new cycle and just as we can't allow
them to dictate our attention we also
can't allow them to dictate the pace of
our solidarity and part of that
solidarity is going to be there to
rebuild razza shortterm longterm I am
proud to give my support my word of
support to trusted brothers and sisters
in the United Kingdom that have started
a walk that have started an endowment to
make sure insh tal that we're there for
the long
run um I think maybe about the role of
woman in in Islam so I've seen some
where hijab some don't but so what's
like the right thing to do so the
question you're asking is you've come
across Muslims some of them sisters who
wear the hijab some don't we say for you
to become a Muslim you have to believe
in Allah his uh books oh sorry sorry
it's telling me I'm moving about to
sorry so you can stay steady it's just
me I keep moving yeah so number one you
believe in God you believe the Quran is
a final message you believe the prophet
Muhammad is the final prophet and you
have to believe in angels the books the
prophets uh the day of judgment Etc so
once you accepted that you're a Muslim
so for example if you said I want to
become a Muslim you can be a Muslim and
not wear the hijab is it a sin yes
however we say for example everyone has
their gradual steps are getting closer
all of us have things that we are
working on you get what I'm trying to
say so to us you can be a Muslim without
wearing the hijab if that's Stopping You
by the way I'm just saying if it's
stopping you so what we say is though
everyone has their gradual progress if
you say you know what I would want to
one day it's totally up to you but the
point of the hijab is why my dear sister
s antia is because
in Islam Islam sees a a woman in a high
regard in the Western World the Western
world has drop woman to a sexual object
Islam says no a woman has more to offer
the reason why the hijab is worn is so
that when a man is talking to you he's
talking to you not talking to something
else and we as men because Islam deals
with the reality of the world we would
love it to be everybody holding hands
but that's not the reality there are
evil people that after evil things
however
the Quran doesn't say women should cover
up because men can't control theel this
a big misconception there is no belief
that oh you're guilty we don't have this
concept that for example in Christianity
they believe the reason why the woman
have pain in birth is because of what
Eve caused Adam to eat from the tree we
don't believe that we don't believe
anybody Bears the soul of somebody else
and not only that in Islam we believe a
woman who's given birth she if she dies
she dies a mar because of what she's
doing the hijab is there so it protects
yourself and the man a man has to also
do his bit so the hijab is an identity
number one to show this is a Muslim
woman yeah and number two we live in a
society in time with the beauty industry
the opposite gender woman I'm reading a
book I I love this book I always quote
it my friends laugh at me I said is this
the only book you read in your life it's
called Beauty sick you should buy it
it's from a non-muslim Au it's called
Beauty sick and she talks about women
who are starving their self to have the
perfect body why should you be judged
based on your looks why should someone
judge you based on your body so that's
why Islam has come to protect you and
also to protect you against other women
how because women tend to look Other
Woman oh she's got this oh look at her
it's when you are covered up that is
your privacy do you get what I'm trying
to say you are judged based on your
intellect not you know there was a woman
a Brazilian woman she died cuz she got
bum
implants she got B implants excuse me
and she died in the process there are
millions of women around the world who
are made to feel ugly who are made to
feel so Islam says no you have a soul
You Are a Human Being you have so excuse
me you have so much to offer than your
looks and your beauty so Islam says you
should not be judged based on your
appearance so when a woman covers up
when she wears the Abaya and she wears
the hijab
Etc men obviously you see as well cuz
men are visual creatures as well it's so
also that men do not fall in love the
wrong way because a man can fall in love
the wrong way you know we are men yeah
what happens is they give the woman
false promises they see a woman they
just like her this lust it's not love so
what did they do they come and abuse
that woman for example there were
studies that showed the amount of woman
cat calling sexually harassed why can
you not walk down the road in peace
why does men have to come and oh
whatever whatever whatever so in Islam
Allah tells us in the Quran he teaches a
man that to lower your gaze to look away
obviously cuz I'm talking to you I'm
trying to obviously I don't want to be
rude and be like you know here looking
here usually in My Religion it teaches
me that I should lower my gaze you get
what I'm trying to say why because Allah
is teaching me do not look at a woman in
a sexually objectified way so that's why
as Muslim men we are told I was actually
standing with one guy there I was
talking to him like this and he turned
his back I said why did you move he said
there was a someone he saw behind me who
was dressed a bit inappropriately he
said I don't I just I just want to I
want to lower my gaze and I thought
that's such a beautiful thing if we
taught our sons and our men that listen
don't look at woman and sexual objective
and by the way not if she's dressed up
in a bikini even if she's wearing a
hijab don't look at her in that way
that's number one number two what Islam
does his sister is deals within a micro
level we don't believe you have a
Ferrari and you have a half naked woman
or you have a chocolate bar what's a
chocolate got to do with a woman so this
is what happens the Western system has
sexually objectified woman that's why
there was a study done in America in a
university they put these wires in the
men's Brains in in his head and they
showed him you know like screw driver
different tools and then they showed the
man the men woman in bikini the part of
the brain that lights up for TOS do you
know what that means he did not see them
as human so when he was looking at these
pictures of woman in bikini the part of
the brain that lights up for Tool use
was lit up this is the problem what we
have today is that men abusing women
dating is the biggest fraud for women TR
I tell you for example how I married my
wife let me tell you you might want to
hear the story are you ready for it yes
okay my wife might be watching
this check this out now this is what I
say when I say Islam on this woman every
five women that every five people that
come to Islam three are women people say
why because this oppressed whatever
check this out when I met my wife
obviously I got to know her a little bit
like I think I spoke to her the first
night the first day I met her I was
talking to for about good five six hours
it was over like um on the phone was
talking it's okay to get to know now
after that I had to go and speak to her
father why she's smiling why is she
smiling cuz she knows yeah the dad is
the he's going to finish you so the
point is this sister I went to the
father to say what I would like your
permission to get to know your daughter
for marriage and he says okay my son you
have my blessing he said thank you for
coming to me would you not appreciate
that imagine a man coming and saying
Auntie I'm I would I would I am
interested in getting to know you for
marriage because you don't know each
other yet be a bit weird if he some and
said can I marry you so I don't even
know you would you not appreciate it and
would your father not appreciate if I
come and said if a man came and said
antia can I speak to your
father I don't know this is something I
don't agree with because I feel like I'm
making my own decisions and I don't want
I feel like if someone's asking for my
dad's blessing it means that I'm not
important enough that I'm making the
decision but my dad is like Superior
good so this is a big misconception this
idea what happens is the following we
think that for example me going to your
father it makes you less you have a
decision in Islam a woman has a right to
say I would not like to marry him for
right A woman has a right to Divorce by
the way you have a right to what we're
saying is the following a man can cuz
this is why they say for example why do
men lie yeah okay why do men lie okay
because for example we are visual
creatures Okay the reason why women wear
makeup and the reason why men lie is
because
men fall for what they see and women
fall for what they hear okay so now what
we're saying is a man could have power
over you easily he can argument he can
you can meet him on the first day lovely
guy Etc no harm he can try to whatever
and he has that power over you you would
agree that a man is stronger than a
woman yes it's a biological fact now
Islam says prevention is better than
cure so Islam says we don't deal with go
try let see cut it from the roots not
drink alcohol then we'll take you to
rehab go do no no no don't go there
don't watch pornography don't do this
stuff so Islam acknowledges reality now
in the real world I agree with you it
should be that he comes and speaks to
you but because Islam knows how Allah
subh Allah has created the woman and the
man Islam sees the man as a threat to
you and it says only a man knows a man
so therefore let him go speak to your
father it's from that angle not from the
angle you cannot make a choice because
in Islam my wife had a right to say say
you know what father I don't want to
marry him I don't want to know him it's
there to protect you because why he can
say let's go on a date because be in
mind sister a woman women are The
Gatekeepers of sex they are The
Gatekeepers of sex if they say no it's a
no so what we're saying is we hear this
start of one night
stands and sometimes there's so many
factors of sexually Transit you know in
the in London there are 1 million people
that have
STDs 1 million people yeah now there's
that there's a fact of him killing you
there was a woman who was kidnapped I
don't know in couple of years ago he was
she was kidnapped and killed yeah so
Islam says these factors are things that
are threatening the woman what as the
protocols that we have to protect her so
it's more of a protection and care so
that's the reason when he speaks to the
father your father when you go to your
father if you went to your father and
said I have a boyfriend your father will
have a discomfort and he's smiling why
because a man knows a man he's like okay
is this guy I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't
help it man stand in one BL okay I'm
going to try with
why sister because your father knows
himself he's like I'm a man that's what
we say to our sisters listen I'm a man
and sometimes when I speak to my wife
she's like listen I'm a woman I know how
woman think I'm like okay I trust you so
your father knows a man so when I if if
a man goes to your father he can SS him
out because otherwise in your dad's mind
he's worried argument sake if you you
may have had boyfriends in your life
probably somebody that us with I'm did
you have you probably had boyfriends in
your life or somebody you was getting to
know right now no now not before um yes
okay your dad will be worried calling
are you okay yeah yes okay good he will
check up on you yes why to make sure I'm
okay and safe and comfortable good do
you think the your boyfriend that you
had before do you think the mother is
ringing him and saying hello are you
okay is she is she is she is she why
because they know he has the power he's
good
but if this I have three daughters I
have three daughters I know the dangers
and threats that face them if I had the
son oh man don't come out now you don't
care cuz you have the ability to fight
you what I'm trying to say Obviously
there are some women who are MMA
fighters that's exceptions to the rule
the point is what it's cuz your dad
cares about you and if your dad had the
power your dad would say what to you
listen and for example let's say you had
a bad breakup your dad will come and say
to you the next person let me talk to
him that's protocol number one by the
way this is how Islam protects number
one speak to the father why now the man
is think can speak to the
father I don't want marriage I just want
to mess around I'm not speaking to your
father oh now you know what it's about
do you see now now now do you agree yeah
okay good so now that's protocol number
one it's not finished yet oh my gosh
sister this is this is the beginning you
know what I had to do that's protocol
number one I had to speak to the father
then after I spoke to the father now I'm
getting to know my wife on marriage
before then he will send a chaperon
either her sister or somebody who when
we get it to know each other who's there
keeping an
eye got eyes on
you okay you're going kill you now we
will go onto don't want to call it date
cuz he has a bad connotation but getting
to know her so we will sometimes go out
to eat we'll go for a walk somebody that
is there that's just with us they don't
need to be there like if we're in the
rest not there say yeah go sit on the
other table I want to ask some questions
you get what I'm trying to say that's
number two so when we're getting to know
each other why because a man can say you
know what yeah you know let me drop you
home yeah he might have bad intentions
he might put something in your drink so
why you have the third person there
keeping an eye on both of you cuz the
prophet Muhammad peace upon him said
when a man and a woman is alone the
third is
Satan because that's how we're created
you get say it's like fire and um petrol
boom explosion so protocol number two
number three do you know what I had to
do Dowry you know dowy yes my wife she
gave me installment plan literal
installment plan yeah she's laughing in
stor of why she asked for a specific and
I said you know
what I have to work a bit hard I have to
do some night shifts for that yeah but
hamdulillah my intentions were what
marriage if I was not interested in
marriage if my intentions were to sleep
around I don't want to meet your dad I
don't want to shaon and you're asking me
for this much money what get out of here
bro I forgive me for saying this but
they can go to some woman who's whatever
for whatever yeah if the man's intention
is that I had no problem you know why
cuz I said I I want to marry you I'm
happy with you the third protocol is
what I had to pay the Mah and obviously
she asked for some goat I was in a bit
of debt but I'm joking the point is this
I had to pay her that you know why that
is her security if me and her divorce
she has that money to rely on Islam does
that make sense yeah makes sense okay S
I think you're going to accept Islam
today I'm joking inshah so the third
thing is what it's a security because
now if that's not there also she can go
back to her father's house her father
will look after her my duty is not to
look after my wife it's my daughter and
my mom cuz men are we believe that are
the head of the house so just to make
that clear I don't want to make a sugar
quot it men are the ones of course I
listen to my wife but men are the ones
that Allah says in the Quran that we are
the protectors and providers we're
full-time bodyguards if you think about
when a thief like you know they talk
about feminism yeah you're a feminist
until the thief breaks get out get up go
see you go imagine me telling my wife
you go and check who's who's breaking
the window it's a thief you go but I
have to go right and and we can die in
the process but we are proud of that now
third number four you have to make a
wedding it doesn't have to be
extravagant simple wedding and you have
to announce it why because if he he
might be a rich guy he has no problem
speaking to your dad but maybe he wants
to keep you secret and you get what I'm
trying to say nah now you need to
announce it to the community this is my
wife by the way guys come to my wedding
here's my wife meet my wife you're
announcing it to to the public so if you
do something wrong the community will
take you to account why you treating her
we came to your wedding why you treating
her like that number three number four
now it doesn't even finish here you you
they told you about woman oppressed yeah
you're probably thinking I I I need to
be a Muslim yeah we need
to you know are you guys are friends
yeah yeah friends yeah okay so the thing
is maybe one day she would want to marry
a Muslim man so the point is this after
that now I Allah says in the Quran what
men are the maintainers and protectors
that means my wife I pay the rent I pay
the shopping I pay the petrol I pay the
tax I pay the insurance I pay for the
kids you are not allowed a woman you
don't need to give a single penny in
Islam you do not need to give one pound
if you was a millionaire and your
husband worked 9 to5 you don't need to
give him one pound that's your money and
you know the money gave the doy that's
yours
the goat that's yours why because Islam
acknowledges but the men is the head of
the household there has to be we believe
in obedience but what does that mean cuz
it has a connotation obedience doesn't
mean he beats you up it's not
permissible in Islam so the point is
what sister does these protocols that
are in place does it not have the
advantage of the woman seems so okay so
what I'm saying I promise you is not a
lie I'm not making it up to make Islam
look I've told you as well then men we
look for obedience so my wife I would
want her to be obedient TOS me in what
not I oppress her but for example Allah
has protocols in place when you get into
a dispute the Quran is such a beautiful
thing it tells you how to manage your
dispute when you guys have friction when
problems
arise why because Islam acknowledges
that woman there's weakness towards them
I believe women are mentally stronger
than us we men we're physically stronger
but you guys are mentally stronger you
speak more you can cry I can't cry to my
friend uh my wife didn't that shut up
get up be a man but as woman you guys
express yourself you can cry so the
point is this is these things are all
set in place for us men to appreciate
that now I'm asking a question if every
man done this would there any be a
situation where a woman is heartbroken
cuz she was used for intimacy and left
probably not never this is the point
here sister if every woman that's why I
say women are The Gatekeepers of sex if
every woman said no I'm not dating you
yeah why because when you go to a you
know when you go to get a Bugatti you
know Bugatti a car Bugatti do you know
you can't be just Rich it's not a matter
of being rich who are you you come to
their store they okay oh I'm A
Millionaire okay no problem we' got many
millionaires who are you because our car
you might be someone who's an idiot who
gives us a bad reputation yeah we say
woman is far more valuable than any car
any diamond that's the reason why when
you go to buy a Bugatti they check who
you are money is you're going to pay for
it anyways what kind of a person you are
what kind of reputation you're going to
give to Bugatti these are the protocols
it goes through now after you've gone
through that if somebody works hard for
something he would appreciate that yes
or no yes that is the point now when
that happens this is the reason why in
Islam the man has to go through all of
this stuff and then when he marries he
appreciates that but if you if a woman
if a man
if a man if a man goes to a woman and
says oh let me take you out for a day
you're so beautiful she's like oh my
gosh Romeo it's such a Charming guy and
he's just his his intention is just to
have sex and
golf you have Dishonored that woman
that's why I believe the Western system
has dropped woman to such a level
forgive me for saying this and I I
disagree with that's why I'm saying it
it's as if they are toilets you're
basically like why do you go toilet to
relieve yourself yes these men are
treating these women like toilets like
you can just go have intimacy relieve
yourself and go away you're breaking
that woman that woman a woman needs
trust yes security yes love yeah thank
you imagine you come and break it break
it break it how are you going to trust
the next man that comes you can't and
this is why women end up breaking the
next man they come across cuz they don't
know how to trust they don't know how to
love anymore because you broke that
that's why Islam says you when I say to
you as a woman your soul your mind Islam
protects that it says no and when you
cover up it says you don't want a man to
lust of you you want him to love you so
that's why Islam says when a woman is
covered up a beauty yeah what happens is
the man is thinking I like her for who
she is not what she possesses you get
what I'm trying to say and that's why
Allah subhana t god almighty has put
these things in place sister so that you
as a woman are protected you are cuz if
you're broken we believe you guys
mothers make Society
like there's one scholar he said women
are half the population of the Earth and
they give birth to the other half isn't
that true yeah thank you so we believe
women are the backbone of the umah
Islamic Nation that's why women have to
be protected because you can easily be
swayed you have your menes your
menopause you get it you have moments
where you say things you don't mean
woman you know woman they speak covertly
if you say yes it means no if you say no
it means yes if he said yes it means
maybe so that Allah has acknowledged how
you are created
that's why Allah has given you the
protocols to protect you and when we
don't do this sister in a nutsh I don't
want to give a
sermon this is why you have women who
are broken who have been abused and
[Music]
Etc sorry this place is a bit of a
mental house by the way I'm the care I'm
the caretaker here okay yeah so so so
the thing is here sister this is why
women if you look for example Bro Look
at studies women are less happy
why because of this bro one night stands
you're going around men are using you
and this is why the woman start behaving
it that way you know why cuz we as men
have let them down if we fixed up and I
I'll be honest we have to sometimes call
it we as men we need to fix up and
that's why I mentioned before I came to
Islam actually when I came to Islam
before Islam I was you know have these
men I'm talking about that was
me I I saw Woman as a human being when I
became Muslim before that I did not see
them as human because my Society made me
like that when I became a Muslim that is
when I was like oh my gosh and I
repented and I changed my ways and this
is the reason why I talk about this why
because Islam has come to honor woman
and that's why answering your question
of the hijab thank you so much I learned
a lot thank you may Allah bless you any
other questions I think I no problem if
you have any other questions sister
where here are you go to Quran um if you
want to if you ever come to Islam insh
you do like I said before there's so
many things these are things I'm just
mentioning but pray to God I did this 13
14 years ago I said God if you're there
guide me to the truth and yeah hopefully
I'll leave that with you sister may
Allah bless you in and if there's
anything you have we're here every
Sunday thank you sister take
care take take